here they are in bracket where it
matters most one dream is actually gonna
be crushed beyond just I mean look at
Sega he looks warmed up earlier you saw
him you know throwing out the jabs are
very warming up and at the beginning of
all his other matches he's just been
poised
yeah obviously these guys have had some
history whether it was online whether is
offline they are here now and they are
fighting again for their tournament
lives what are these two players we'll
move on to the top eight for the only
one of them only one of them they both
have a lot to say pay attention make
sure you go ahead and give all
[Music]
we pick here changhua versus Yoshimitsu
this is how the battles gonna go down it
is the most precious character in the
history of all everything what a friend
yes I agree Yoshimitsu is a princess
let's go
that's my baby that's why I like you
shoot it sir
anyways we're gonna go right into this
nothing wrong there and already so Leo
is coming through try the to fly like a
person you probably got that throat
immediately with the duck yeah he was
trying to go with that piece line a real
quick look at the top two second hit
caught it with a run counter hold on
wait a minute don't grab her like that
Wow it senses wake up with these plates
at the time delay able to still get the
hit nice though able to get the two to
beat and the follow-up here play some
wait a bit sliding right into that
health bar trying to put a simple guy in
the yellow zone is singing it's so much
respect right now we've punished it's
pretty close but you can't count about
the Newt might come out it Oh
spin that bar yo that's so well matched
both of these [ __ ] right back at it
gonna twist up and clip the leg a Signia
gets on the board first that's the thing
that we're going back and forth at such
high speeds but Cena able to make the
big commitment at the very end follow up
keeping it safe beautiful all beautiful
stuff good lead here for septic I got to
the trough first they both at the hand
on the trigger but the fastest hand
at this time blue bar positioning
self-closing that one out nothing close
about that one Oh what run a piece why
convincingly though that last round
really showed his ability didn't just
out space the situations that the Signia
was being put in doing so fast of this
in diffusion with rounds with matches
it's all over something I really wanted
to see keep looking safe approach
gentlemen taking advantage of the
situation
oh he tried to interrupt both of those
times I'm getting counter hit clobbered
right now try to push him off again
Zeppelin I just getting all these P hits
here yeah just everywhere oh my gosh
five baby to victory here no that would
have been too crazy how many massive
five times again wasn't afraid to go
from the four crowd sweet day not to be
surprised if you went for it again oh oh
dance there caught him stepping you
watching me a little too much they go
into that big kick too close for comfort
there that's for the 9k unable to get it
to get a nice punish they're definitely
pushing closer towards the end of the
ring gonna have to be very very careful
again here comes Signia this is where
kit start oh my gosh the bard keep it in
its position it's singing of checking's
epic I with those horizontals knowing
that he wants to escape out on a launch
and to a CEO and I promise mother will
watch over us all because put the stops
let's see what happens goes for the mid
option here we go senior having another
opportunity that's all we punish that's
the way footage oh my goodness I didn't
see his what he was doing but I'm sure
he did something now that was all he
probably thought is very grass
you know he's a character who when he's
doing well you're gonna hear it from him
he can also take his licks to what he's
losing he plays with the emotion he let
out a quick sigh relief we caught that
shouts out to the camera crew here just
making sure production you know what
that is one game oh yeah and I think
most of the time we've seen him in the
topic we seen him down early on he was
able to make the comeback
what if he's gonna be able to do it
again this time should be a rematch X
versus Y again one of these two players
will be able to get in our top eight but
only one the other one will have to sit
and cry here we go match number two's
deprecating up 1-0 who gets the grab Wow
nice able to get the full extension
there follow-up that is obviously not
what he wanted but look he gives up some
of his life they're gonna break their I
don't know sure weird you need it but
doesn't matter look at that life just
whittled away yeah with the Texas Yoshi
loses hope yeah he does have to mix it
to where he can actually give it to them
if they break it he gets it back yes
it's really weird just so much stuff
going on your imagine Yoshi Yoshi yeah
absolutely
Wow the double kicks that get the follow
up combo out of that Oggy situation goes
low keeping his save looking for the GI
before I follow up for signe accompany
us up do not crouch and he gets the tech
catches well to follow up here what are
you gonna do with him oh he tried to
whip bunny [ __ ]
I like the idea for both those gentlemen
sitting it's just they're a little too
far away a to keep things sleep and
quick
I tend starters for both of these
characters and he's trying to pay
something else I'm things he's like my
thinking is not falling for it and so
charges I'm gonna go in the driver seat
for just a little bit oh and he caught
him he made him flinch and look at that
he's gonna close it out here with quite
the exclamation point right now he is on
set point with this round
all right back to work anyway going up
keeping us safe this time yeah and right
back atcha let's G I itself was going
forward a third time and a fourth and
yep right back and she gets to leap
though hit off of that GI who's
interesting he had the door knocker here
I think he was trying to hit put the
frame it but wasn't able to confirm him
all right fighting back he still has all
that meter though he's gonna have to use
it eventually here we go go watch it
oh nice demo this a big Signia now what
though the reasoning and instead just
looking to close it out the normal way
now looking for the ring I'll backtalk
just a little bit too much of an oaky
situation what this should be a punish
close it out here yes
no into the meter Oh time yeah but that
doesn't have the bar for launch at stage
it's gonna play a safe a Signia after
the advantage wore off that a a check
yeah
staying alive of course and he has a ton
of meter here he's gonna have to utilize
it in some way goes with the door
knocker again get off me two rounds I
could close it out what oh yeah the
person on the losing side fighting back
fantastic with wonderful signal oh my
goodness Oh Walken something about this
sole charge activation has changed the
shape of this match the course of
history has changed they're working on a
perfect but Steph says no today how
about a comeback of my own no denial two
rounds of peep but peace Zef looking to
close things off can he do it or will
Signia force a decisive game no Signia
coming from behind again we see this
before he is right now playing with the
momentum on his side proctor in the back
of the head didn't do anything with it
in that situation checks insignia now
boots his way in he wants to have a
conversation with you stand right here X
I'm trying to talk to you stand up case
launch like it ooh nope no attempt
they're trying to put a kid not able to
get anything but a good throw Tech these
men throwing out moves they had thrown
out yet trying to save the big stuff now
oh gee I'm not able to get it but look
at this flashing yellow now gotta be
very careful here a lot of respect and
walk bandits going down to the wire out
of it and that is it and Signia stays on
the board
Saif Akatsuki it'll get three straight
rounds like please I I just want to
continue to watch fighting games
probably already checked into the
hospital I'm good yeah always doing this
doing this to me time look so focused
that is the gamer leaned forward the
lead is five but now he's going to the
okay we'll see we'll see comes down to
this final match between these two tied
up what a piece
dzifa Kyra Signia a battle for top eight
[Music]
that stage man are we gonna see some
nasty stuff are we gonna go out of the
ring any crybabies to stay under she
doesn't want anything until he pried
under the fire yes don't hit me like
that I don't like fire okay I'm not okay
with it nice good GI I like it
a short at all watching the low trying
to get that oh hello drive up I jump and
there's the launch yes 6k to get the job
done all right
look at that first round first blood
here from zeph the guy who wants to
continue with the lead nice with
Punisher from cydia again stuff that I
really starting to utilize these tools
try to bake things out so beautifully
and get the regio bait out with the for
for a full charge that's a little he was
dedicated to that GI he fully knew there
was gonna be a reaction signal oh my
gosh exceptionally clean but again the
same position he was in last game but we
saw what happened there's nothing more
dangerous than Signia from behind Tom
China thumb found on of goes under this
time itself using all of the momentum
buttons that changes the per box of the
character in order to switch position on
however that's a big he's gonna answer
the call possum up well you got two
rounds alright time to wake up Oh bless
up here we go the follow up here again
you wanted something big day you went
the route pic now going for the magic
carpet exponentially but Signia wakes up
by turn soul charge does you have to be
careful you cannot win he said that
would be a danger oh my goodness here we
go now anything will do it just about
any table whole situation was gonna do
it for either one of each element
there's gonna be it and several guys
gonna get the job done no you can't stop
take a video clip but what's up oh hey
push it back out of public on the street
you know that that's all it's all the
good that for a while he's been wanting
to do that but man guy we'll move on
into our top eight but gotta give it up
for City event yes white the performance
throughout the entire day really showing
that skill but men great stuff for both
of these players
toppy to fire things off it's gonna be
Omega D are going up again tomahawk the
century just so much energy talkies all
over the screen the whole time while
Omega likes to control space for its ads
right he wants you to come to the area
where he would like you as we saw I
guess I'm a god I believe no it was it
was a different size versus hockey match
but it's the same principle right come
here